hey girl i know you've been with a lot
of guys
and it felt like something's missing 80
of the time statistically speaking
but i got a little bit more than you're
used to something i've been
keeping under wraps cause i'm the whole
package baby
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
saturday night hopping out the uber got
my charm good looks and a sense of humor
black button up
shirt splash of cologne clubs pack dj
spinning post malones
see your honey by the bar in a
skin-tight dress throw a couple of
shapes and she seems impressed
touch her arm just a little can i buy
you a drink make eye contact as our
glasses blink
she's playing with her hair and she
laughs at my jokes so i order us another
two bacardi and coke
now her hands on my knee and she's
stroking my thigh she says she's never
been with a british guy
it's the moment that i fear don't know
how she'll react compared to other boys
i'm a little more intact so i whisper in
her ear don't be
surprised but i'm 100 uncircumcised
foreskin
i've got a foreskin just a heads up baby
it's a warning
i wanna make sure cause i've been burned
before when i show them my foreskin they
show me the door
girl i hope you've got an open mind
cause my dick's just like god designed
i've got a foreskin
girl let me be blunt there'll be a
little bit more going into your
continuing on in the hunt for a lady who
will make my shaft stand up like slim
shade head home with a hottie from the
discotheque feel lucky cause she's
wearing a turtleneck start fumbling
before we're even in my condo hope she
doesn't mind that my dong's wearing a
poncho so i tell her before we get hot
and heavy i'm hooded like a monk in a
monastery
she doesn't understand but i soldier
wrong when we [ __ ] a girl i don't need
lotion on my natural state has been
preserved
cocked like a featherless baby bird so
once the love train has disembarked
you're going to come face to face with a
pink aardvark what i'm saying girl
don't be traumatized i'm 100
uncircumcised
foreskin i've got a foreskin it's kind
of like my prick's got an awning
i know a lot of jewish guys get the snip
tell the rabbi thanks guy you can keep
the tip
i just tell it how it is no need for
debate and i know that i'm at a higher
risk for aid i got a foreskin flapping
like a kite in the breeze and i
frequently clean it so there's never any
cheesy smiles on my wedding day and i
won't let this one get away
every other girl left i was so afraid
that we never had
sex i said i'd wait so we stand in the
chapel in front of the priest and i lean
in trying to be discreet
and right at the moment i should say i
do i'm like babe there's a secret i must
tell you
suddenly you scream we all turn around
outside there's a building burning down
i push through the crowd as the fire
roars there's a woman at a window on the
very top floor
crying and screaming like a crazy lady
shouting out somebody please save my
baby
i'll catch him i replied i'm a hundred
percent
uncircumcised foreskin i've got a
foreskin
so i stretched it out and then caught
him the most marvelous sight that you've
ever seen turned my pork and beans into
a trampoline
everybody cheers i'm the hero the men
told me they wish theirs could regrow
thanks to my foreskin the child survived
though sadly the woman in the fire
died foreskin i've got a foreskin so
soft that the kids start snoring
foreskin i've got a foreskin and now
i've got to raise this orphan
foreskin i've got a foreskin in a few
months he'll start crawling
foreskin i've got a foreskin he's a jew
that's a fact i'm ignoring